mein name ist luca meine lieben
zuschauer herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einer neuen episode von dem
sagenumwobenen format amazon fällt
schnee ich bin frisch aus dem urlaub
zurückgekehrt meine lieben freunde ich
bin auch ein bisschen braun geworden
nein aber ein bisschen bartwuchs
bekommen aber heute soll es nicht um
eine grandiose männlichkeit geht wenig
vorhanden sondern um amazon fans bzw
allgemeiner gefasst um online shopping
fällt und ich würde sagen wir fangen
direkt an mit diesem kleid das ist ein
flamingo kleid und es sitzt echt
ziemlich gut schneider bestellende
person zu hause angekommen ist
allerdings dass sie ja aber wir bleiben
direkt bei uns die sachen dass jedes
nämlich irgendwo meerjungfrauen decken
ding ja keine ahnung wo man sich sowas
bestellen würde angekommen ist
allerdings nicht irgendwie solle coole
decke lka schlafsack meerjungfrauen
design whatever sondern einfach und das
hier das ist sieht ein bisschen aus wie
patrick moll bekommen nun allerdings zu
einem bikini beziehungsweise einem top
oder oberteil oder keine ahnung wie
frauen das nennen das jetzt auf jeden
fall das kleidungsstück dass sich eine
person bei amazon bestellen wollte
beziehungsweise so wurde mit dem produkt
geworben angekommen ist allerdings dass
hier das produkt was so klein dass sie
es einfach der baby katze angezogen
haben ihr kommen wir nun allerdings weg
von angst die sachen und begeben uns
wieder in die mysteriöse welt der handy
hüllen in meiner letzten folge amazon
feld haben sie auch schon bei handy
hüllen angeschaut handy hülle auf der
einfach eine heroinspritze zu sehen ist
also letztes mal war schon komisch aber
er heute schieben wir mal wieder absolut
den vogel ab dass jetzt einfach eine
handy hülle mit einer frau drauf die
sich gerade haare entfernen lässt
er denkt es geht nicht schlimmer dann
zeige ich euch hätten wir die nächste
handy hat das ist ein älterer herr mit
einer windel und einem krückstock ja die
würde ich direkt auf mein handy
klatschen fahrzeug die windel krückstock
handy heute allerdings noch nicht
komplett aus den wolken gerissen hat man
könnt ihr euch natürlich auch diese im
juni kaufen
das ist einfach kokain was
ihr wollt noch ein geileres design
anschauen heißt diese ohne das war geil
ist geil auf der agenda der wahnsinn
also ich bin persönlich ja echt echt
großartig schubkarren kommen allerdings
weg von den handy hüllen und wieder
zurück zu anziehsachen bzw zu schmuck
und zwar sind dass hier dinge die sich
eine person bestellen wollte angekommen
sind allerdings dient das hier ist eine
black mesz gesichtsmaske die eine person
bei amazon entdeckt hat und sie sagte
sich halt hey ich will was gutes tun für
meine haut ich bestelle mir diese maske
angekommen ist allerdings dass es sei
traurig weil die leute dafür geld
ausgehe war irgendwie total witzig als
nächstes komme zu einer person die sich
mal wiegen wollte und sich
dementsprechend eine vage bestellt hat
angekommen ist allerdings keine
irgendwie normale wagen mit einem
durchmesser von kanal um 14 zentimeter
sondern das hier ja da ist es schon ein
highlight wenn du dich überhaupt darauf
stellen ganz kommen wir nun zu einer
bestellung die eine mutter getätigt hat
und wir wissen ja dass ältere personen
oftmals so ein bisschen nicht so richtig
gut klar kommt mit neuer technik mit
neuen möglichkeiten dinge zu bestellen
sie wollte sich eine leggins bestellen
und angekommen ist das hier ja wenn du
fünf zentimeter lange beine hast dann
passt die bestimmt super kombi nun
allerdings wieder weg von den anti
sachen beziehungsweise zu accessoires
schmuck et cetera und hin zu deko
artikeln und zwar zu einem teppich
der sieht so aus ich würde mir auf
keinen fall bestellen weil es einfach
lässig hat teppich ist ein mann dachte
sich aber dennoch haye kommen so ein
lila teppich einfach super bei uns im
zimmer rhein angekommen ist allerdings
kein riesiger sofa teppich sondern dass
hier
ein fußabtreter ja viel spaß beim füße
abtreten der nächste online shopping
fail ist wieder so eine sache da denke
ich mir
das hätte ich auch von mir kommen können
und zwar wollte sich ein typ ein kissen
bestellen mit seinem gesicht drauf und
das wollte er seiner freundin schenken
das hat nicht ganz geklappt voller
produktion und angekommen ist dann das
hier ja da wird sich die freundin
bestimmt mega darüber freuen zudem hat
sich der gleiche typ auch gedacht hey
ich denke meine freundin ein kissen und
die neue dvd 5 die shades of grey
angekommen ist allerdings keine dvd von
dem film sondertasten 50 shades of great
allerdings schon zum vorletzten damals
unfällen und zwar hat sich eine person
einen boxsack für 20 dollar aus china
bestellt und natürlich klarer kann man
nicht viel erwarten
aber das hat ging so schnell und so
kaputt geht hätte glaube ich niemand
gerechnet allerdings beide damen und
herren nun kommen wir auch schon zum
letzten online-shopping feld für heute
und zahlt sich eine person paar schuhe
bestellt und es sind auch die schuhe
angekommen allerdings zweimal der linke
schuh
ja wirklich wahnsinn amazon an der stadt
heute ich will jetzt nicht beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn euch meine maker
fertigen der dümmste zufällig gefallen
hat also nicht meinen daumen hoch unter
dem video laden schreibt noch mal gerne
in die kommentare
ob ich das ganze eventuell in einer
woche noch mal hoch laden soll also
sollen dritten teil haben wir zum fällt
mir jetzt auf jeden fall mega viel spaß
macht die ganze sache näher anzuschauen
und noch eine ganz kurze sache diese
beiden neuen rudi ist also ein weißer
und ein schwarzer wo die beide mit einem
luxus rottstock vorne drauf genähten
kommen genau in einem monat in den
lukasz ob also am 09
gibt es zwei neue produkte zudem kommt
am 9.9.99 doch ein neues kissen in den
shop also tatsächlich sogar drei neue
produkte und wahnsinn würde ich mir
direkt den kalender eintragen aber gut
freuen ich würde auf jeden fall jetzt
das heutige video erst mal beenden ich
hoffe wirklich dass es euch gefallen hat
mir machen diese amazon fels unfassbar
viel spaß wenn ihr da weiterhin bock
drauf habt dann abonniert gerne einen
kanal dann verpasst du den nächsten teil
nicht und jetzt kommt doch das auto
[Musik]